hey guys in this video I'm going to talk
about what really causes gallstones
okay there's a myth out there that a
high-fat diet will cause gallstones
that is absolutely not true let's go
into that a little bit more most stones
are cholesterol stones okay so it's a
concentrated amount of cholesterol
because there's not enough bile so the
real deep underlying cause of a
gallstone is bile deficiency bile is a
fluid that is made in liver and
concentrated in the gall bladder by 20x
and it's used to help you extract
nutrients from the food especially like
extracting the fat soluble vitamins
essential fatty acids and then the
pancreas releases enzymes to help break
it down even more so really the
underlying cause of gallstones are a
lack of bile because bile keeps the
stone from developing it keeps
cholesterol from forming a stone and
also it disposes of excess cholesterol
so bile is very very very very important
okay and if you had your gallbladder out
you're gonna be deficient in ball even
more because now you don't have a sack
to allow the bile to be concentrated so
the original reason probably they took
it out as you had stones and now they
take it out and now we have a deficiency
of bile even more it trickles down so
you might switch the problem from a
stone to another problem of a lack of
absorption of fat tile vitamins or
omega-3 fatty acids or an essential fact
called DHA which is good for your brain
and your heart so it's hard to pull all
those in so without bile it's like
washing your hands without soap now let
me talk about things that can trigger
the loss or deficiency of bile okay so
these are not direct causes they're
indirect causes because they have to
then do things that then decrease bile
so high levels of estrogen can decrease
bile and increase your risk of getting
stones from hormone replacement therapy
birth control being pregnant
all of these actions can increase your
chance of getting a stone because it
depletes file and by the way the
symptoms of low bile would be bloating
indigestion gas constipation because
bile
acts as a lubricant also right shoulder
pain headaches on the right side pain in
the upper trap on the right side pain
and the scapula on the right side
anything on the right side because it
can swell up and be congested and cause
a triggering of a nerve that goes right
up into this side of your body I put
some links down below for more
information about that high levels of
cortisol can also deplete your bile
cortisol is a stress hormone so stress
can increase your risk of stones because
it decreases bile and that can also
include medication type cortisol like
prednisone for example because one of
the side effects is it increases your
chance of getting a stone this is a
biggie increase of insulin can deplete
your bile I mean a lot of people have
too much insulin probably 60 to 70
percent of the population so the thing
that triggers insulin is course the
carbs frequent eating but here's the
here's one point I want to bring up when
you combine carbs or bread or pasta with
protein or carbs sugar with fat you
greatly exaggerated the release of
insulin so if you're doing a high-fat
diet with a high sugar diet and many of
the experiments they do with mice and
they're calling it a high-fat diet when
really it's a high sugar and a high fat
diet but they don't tell you that you're
gonna find that probably you're gonna
find problems with gall stones or a lot
of other side effects but the point is
higher amounts of fat with low sugar low
carb it's totally safe it does not
create a problem it's the combination of
the higher fat with the high sugar or
the combination of higher protein with
sugar together that's deadly okay so
anyway we want to keep our insulin low
if we want to prevent gall stones low
fat diets low fat diets vegan diets
basically don't have enough
saturated fats to trigger enough bile so
this is interesting because people think
that it's the fat that causes the
problem but saturated fat is the thing
that triggers the release of bile you
need saturated fats so I personally
experienced this in college when I made
some meatloaf okay and my grandmother
was really great at making meatloaf she
sent me the the recipe I didn't read it
I scanned it it said take like a pound
of hamburger take some bread Brett yeah
bread mix it together bake it put some
ketchup on it right so I didn't read the
fine line which says drain all the
grease out of it I just kept the grease
in there like all the bread just soaked
it up like a sponge and I ate that whole
thing now think about it I combined all
the saturated fat with the protein with
the bread deadly combination massive
spike of insulin I had a gallbladder
attack I thought I had a stone but it
was just a gallbladder attack and in the
middle of the night so basically if I
kept doing that or eventually developed
stones but a low fat diet will increase
your chance of developing a stone
because you don't have enough bile so
don't be afraid of the saturated fat as
long as you keep your carbs low alright
so the next thing is a fatty liver which
by the way comes from high levels of
insulin though now if there's too much
fat in the liver it's going to obstruct
the function of the liver and to that
degree you're not going to be able to
make bio because bile is made by the
liver cells so if half of it is fatty
that means you get half of the
production of bile so really this could
be a culprit in why a person develops
stones it's a fatty liver how do you
know if you have a fat liver just look
down at your stomach if you have a gut
you probably have a fatty liver but the
best way is to get an ultrasound and
just check it out anti acids can also
disrupt your ability to make file and
use bile and so what happens is the
reason why you need to take any acids in
the first place is you don't have enough
acid now if this sounds strange for you
watch the video down below on an acidic
stomach because what causes that is a
low stomach acids I know sounds strange
but what happens
you don't have enough stomach acid what
happens the valve doesn't close and the
acid comes up if you have enough acid in
your stomach the valve closes nicely and
you don't feel the acid reflux so the
fact that you need antacids tells me
that you don't have enough stomach acid
and stomach acid is one of the triggers
for the bile to release from the gall
bladder okay so anyway if you don't have
enough of that trigger coming from the
stomach this can actually really create
a dysfunctional gallbladder and create
a whole series of problems a chain
reaction that occurs just because the
stomach pH is not correct and one last
thing if you're not consuming enough
vegetables you're not going to be able
to feed your microbes in your large
intestine the food that they need to
help manifest the quantities of microbes
that you need to help recycle bile so
90% or 95% of all the bile is recycled
and a big portion of that is done by the
friendly microbes in your gut so if you
don't have those microbes there that
could be the reason why you can't
recycle biome another common cause okay
don't have enough bile you start
increasing your risk of getting stones
all right anyway I hope this helped you
understand what's really behind the
stones and put your comments down below
I'm curious what you think about this so
I want to know about what you think
about this video so please comment below
and tell me what you think